when you were getting started you used
to play piano and sing yeah I wanted to
be a musician when I was a kid you might
be a musician and I was told that
sometimes because there you were playing
for people that didn't understand
English and he would pretend that you
could sing in English why would you do
that yeah now it's out no oh yeah yeah
so I apologize for these people who
Paige drinks for years and thought he
was English they probably thought oh
this is cool this guy knows you know the
thing is I sung in a piano bar and and
one day the owner said I have one of my
most important client here and it's his
wife's birthday they want English they
giving you great tip they're having 20
bottles it's great we need English I
didn't know any song in English I didn't
speak English it was like 15 years ago
didn't need English yeah I don't know so
I made up a language that sounded like
English to them and they were thrilled
they were so happy they see they didn't
speak English but they you were English
you know I what I were like yeah it's
I'm fast thing I wanted to hear because
I want to hear what your interpretation
it what's I want to hear you saying this
fake English because I want to know what
it would you do that was that was
gibberish I know I want to hear it
oh yeah I really want to hear this it's
a chance for us to hear what English
sounds like the rest of the world is
this a little a small piano yeah that
I'm putting yeah okay I flew here I
thought I was gonna experience the
American dream
and Here I am yeah that's a week okay I
would have a very long intro to think
about the words
I'll bring oh that's great bring the
lights down a little bit spice is
romantic that one Atlantic my pearls to
pray the prayers fries
[Laughter]
and greatest greatest loves I don't even
know what I'm saying
I took a modern day the streets down so
low
and indeed I'm a lot and say damn sober
[Music]
and brain
I'm afraid free Nana Stronach are the
pre InnoCentive person on him ray
and I love when they go like this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right got em away American dream it
will be available on Netflix on March 6
I love this guy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you